all right my friends it's time for
another look at fake history you may
have seen my video on the fake history
of Saladin where I pointed out that
although much extolled in the West for
magnanimous and even chivalrous Behavior
the Kurdish Sultan was what we would
call today and at the sake of using an
anachronism a radical Muslim who
persecuted enslaved and beheaded
Christians including for not embracing
Islam now let's look at a similar but
much lesser known example of this
phenomenon of westerners gushing over
what are otherwise fanatical Muslims
enter Muhammad bin D shagi although he
is better known today as Alp arsin a
Turkish honorific that means brave lion
for the remainder of this video I will
refer to him by his given name Muhammad
this Muhammad born in 1033 was Sultan of
the selic Turks from 1063 to 1072 and
the selic Turks were the one Muslim
group that committed so many atrocities
throughout Asia Minor and The Holy Land
slaughtering and slaving tens if not
hundreds of thousands of Christians and
desecrating and torching thousands of
churches all of which culminated in the
calling of the First Crusade according
to Muslim sources Muhammad Sultan
Muhammad was a fundamentalist nisam al-
mul his vizer and a formidable man
himself said of the young Sultan he was
exceedingly imperious and because he was
so Earnest and fanatical in his beliefs
and disapproved of the shaf right I
lived in con Conant fear of him right is
one of four approved schools of Sunni
law or singular even so the vizer is
saying that Sultan Muhammad who followed
the hanfi MB was so intolerant of any
opposing schools of thought even though
they were fully approved by Islam that
he terrified his own vizir how then
would Muhammad Sultan Muhammad Alp Arsen
have felt about Christians we shall soon
see as an example of his many exploits
soon after becoming Sultan between 1064
and 1065 Muhammad besieged Ani the
capital of Armenia once inside as Muslim
Warriors armed with two knives in each
hand and an extra one in their mouths
according to sources began to
mercilessly Slaughter the inhabitants of
the entire city and pile up their bodies
one on top of the other before torturing
it the sources talk about innumerable
boys and girls with PR and bright and
pretty faces being carried off into
slavery with their mothers the main
source is Matthew of adessa but the most
Savage treatment was always reserved for
those visibly proclaiming their
Christianity clergy and monks were
burned to death While others were flayed
alive from head to toe all on Sultan
Muhammad's orders every Monastery and
church before this Ani was known as the
city of a thousand one churches was
pillaged desecrated and set a flame
crosses were ritually broken except for
a large gilded one which Muhammad sent
to the cff in Baghdad as a trophy of war
or of jihad not only do several
Christian sources document the sack of
armenia's capital Ani one contemporary
succinctly notes that Muhammad quote
rendered Ani a desert by massacr and
Fire end quote but so do Muslim sources
often in apocalyptic
terms I wanted to enter the city and see
it with my own eyes one Arab said I
tried to find a street without having to
walk over the Corpses but that was
impossible and that's from Alfred
Friendly's book The Dreadful day a
little wonder that for contemporary
Christians Sultan Muhammad was quote
like a beast crazed by its bloodthirsty
nature a drinker of blood a venomous
serpent a ferocious animal to quote
again from Matthew of adessa Chronicle
for the Greek Michael adeles a
contemporary of Sultan Muhammad Muhammad
was simply quote the Antichrist unquote
due to Sultan Muhammad's ravaging of
Christian territory before long the
Eastern Roman Empire Byzantium responded
in the person of Emperor Romanus
diogenes the fourth he led a large army
to meet and fight Muhammad's forces near
manzer in 1071 chapter four of my sword
and Scimitar is devoted to that battle
Not only was it a catastrophic defeat
for the Christians but Romanos became
the first Roman emperor in over a
thousand years to experience the igny of
being captured on the field of battle
and here's where things get very
interesting Sultan Muhammad ended up
releasing Romanos in exchange for a huge
Ransom and because of this all that is
remember today of Sultan Muhammad this
Drinker of Christian blood this Blood
crazed Beast this Antichrist is that he
was wait for it magnanimous and
chivalrous sound familiar now rather
than comb through my life library for
quotes asserting Muhammad's magnanimity
and these are many if memory does not
fail me I decided to try out this chat
gbt by asking it which authors say Alp
arsin was magnanimous for releasing
Romanos and it gave me several examples
including the following Steven runman in
his famous work the history of the
Crusades runman refers to Alp arin's
release of Romanos as an act of
magnanimity he highlights that despite
the Byzantine Emperor being captured
after a significant defeat Alp arsin
showed Mercy by sparing him rather than
executing him which was common practice
in such situations at the time it also
gave me Alan Palmer in the decline and
fall of the Ottoman Empire Palmer refers
to Alp arson arin's release of Romanos
as an example of chivalry and Noble
conduct in contrast to the often brutal
nature of medieval warfare David Nicole
in his book The Crusades a short history
Nicole discusses the event and notes
that AR that Alp arin's decision that's
why I like to just call him
Muhammad to release Romanos was likely
motivated by political calculation oh
good for him but also an act of
magnanimity that contrasted with the
harsher Norms of Warfare at the time it
also gave me Bernard Lewis the renowned
historian of the Middle East in his book
The Middle East a brief history of the
last 2,000 years briefly touches upon
the release of Romanos and suggests that
Alp arin's act demonstrated generosity
and wisdom I also asked chat gbt
directly was Alp arelin magnanimous to
Romanos diogenes after the battle of
manzer in 1071 and this is how it
responded Yes Alp arsin the sgic sultan
demonstrated magnanimity towards Romanos
4 diogenes the Byzantine emperor after
the battle of maniker in 1071 despite
the overwhelming victory of the sgic
forces Alp arsin acted with relative
Mercy toward the defeated Romanos which
is often cited as an example of his
magnanimity rather than executing him or
imprisoning him for Life Alp arsin
reportedly treated Romanos with respect
and dignity he is said to have had a
respectful conversation with the emperor
asking for his well-being and offering
him generous treatment however after
Romanos was released and returned to
Constantinople his own Court turned
against him and he was eventually
deposed Ed blinded and imprisoned Alp
arin's Mercy therefore did not directly
lead to a positive outcome for Romanos
but it was certainly a magnanimous
gesture in contrast to the ruthless
Norms of medieval warfare the event
reflects Alp arin's character and
political approach showing a level of
compassion and respect toward an enemy
which stands out in history as an
example of chivalric conduct all right
that's enough of that
now back to some serious facts there are
two fundamental problems with these
claims that I just read to you first
although much has been made by Western
historians concerning Sultan Muhammad's
apparent magnanimity in fact it
completely accorded with Sharia Islamic
law which requires Muslim leaders to
dispense with captives in whichever one
of three ways best serves Islam's
interests one execution two slavery
three Freedom Often by ransoming now
considering that the Sultan's Fatimid
Shia Rivals were launching devastating
raids on his Southern domains and that
the execution of the Christians Emperor
would likely provoke A Renewed Roman
offensive whereas clemency to Romanos
might ease hostilities and fill the
suljic coffers with money Muhammad
wisely concluded on release for ransom
even Romanos himself had shrewdly told
the sultan that quote killing me will
not be of any use to you end quote so in
and of itself there was nothing
magnanimous in in Muhammad's release of
Romanos for ransom based on the
circumstances it was by far the best of
Muhammad's options allowing tensions
with the Christians to ease so the Turks
could focus on the Shia fatimids and
filling their War chest with much needed
gold the second and even bigger problem
here is that while Muslim accounts do
confirm that Muhammad released the
emperor they make abundantly clear that
there was nothing magnanimous about it
quite the opposite according to this
book Turkish smth and Muslim symbol the
Battle of maner by Carol
hillenbrand the following are all quotes
from Muslim sources as to how Muhammad
actually treated the Christian Emperor
you are too trivial in my view for me to
kill you the sultan is said to have said
to Romanos before his Turks take him to
the person who pays most when no one was
reportedly interested in purchasing the
dog of the Romans as he's called
Muhammad scoffed that that was because
the dog is better than he is
dog by the way is one of Islam's main
epithets for
Christians the Muslim Chronicles in that
book also say that Muhammad struck him
three or four blows with his hand and
when Romanos collapsed on the floor he
kicked him a similar number of times he
put him in Chains and fettered his hand
to his neck he pulled his hair and put
his face to the ground while informing
him you and your troops are food for the
Muslims and so
on meanwhile and if you will recall chat
gbt said this Alp arelin reportedly
treated Romanos with respect and dignity
he is said to have had a respectful
conversation with the emperor asking for
his well-being and offering him generous
treatment Alp arin's Mercy was certainly
a magnanimous gesture in contrast to the
ruthless Norms of medieval warfare the
event reflects Alp arsen's character and
political approach showing a level of
compassion and respect toward an enemy
which stands out in history and is as an
example of chivalric conduct
so there it is yet another example of
fake history and as with saladin's fake
history it too is dedicated to
transforming a jihadist Muslim War
leader into a paragon of magnanimity
enjoy